bribery had a clear meaning we have been
listening there to the Republicans
question their witness the the law
expert earlier and now it's professor
Noah Feldman who has speaking once again
at the impeachment inquiry which is now
in the House Judiciary Committee which
has heard from for constitutional law
professors who have talked about why
they think the case for impeachment
should go on or shouldn't go on let's
bring in Heidi Joe Castro who is on
Capitol Hill for us in Washington DC
Heidi again this is a new phase in the
impeachment inquiry into President
Donald Trump remind our viewers of
what's been happening over the last
three hours
sure so today was the first day that the
House Judiciary Committee has had
control of this impeachment inquiry why
is that such a big deal well because
this is the committee that is charged to
initiate impeachment proceedings those
actual articles of impeachment which is
really synonymous to a crinimal and a
criminal indictment in a sense that the
president would face eventually if he
goes to a trial before the Senate and
setting up the the writing of those
articles today was the findings of the
actual Trump's dealings with Ukraine
that we heard developed over weeks of
testimony from the fact witnesses making
the case according to Democrats that
Trump put his personal interests ahead
of those of national security when he
pressured Ukraine to announce that it
was investigating his political rival
Joe Biden while Trump was withholding
security aid to Ukraine now the question
today isn't so much whether that
happened isn't what charges Trump may
face but rather whether those
accusations rise to the level of
impeachable offenses and from these four
witnesses who are all legal
constitutional scholars three who were
in the majority had a unanimous
answer - yes this is impeachable
offenses in fact one set of this is not
impeachable then nothing is and in fact
the history is watching and the
conclusion of how this how this
concludes isn't solely determining the
fate of President Trump but also what
happens for u.s. presidents that come
down the line in the future and we heard
some very stark language coming from
these three witnesses called by
Democrats one said that Trump has
attacked each of the Constitution's
safeguards against establishing a
monarchy another said that she had never
before seen a US president double down
in violating his oath to faithfully
protect the US Constitution now the one
person who is a man disagreement is that
fourth constitutional scholar Jonathan
Turley who was called by Republicans now
it's notable that in his published
opening statement he said that if these
allegations against Trump were proven if
he indeed withheld security assistance
Ukraine for political gain then yes that
would be impeachable but he puts in a
big cog yet he says that has not been
proven in fact he calls the evidence
that has been developed thin and says
that if this moves forward into the
Senate for a trial it would be the
fastest impeachment trial on the
thinnest evidence and he is the sole
voice on this panel representing the
argument of Republicans that are
attacking the process of this
impeachment inquiry all right how do you
thank you very much for that let's also
speak now to Melanie Sloan who's a
former federal prosecutor live with us
from Washington DC who's been with us
for the last three hours in fact
listening to these hearings and Melanie
as you suspected when we spoke earlier
Republicans so far actually only
focusing on their witness Jonathan
Turley during the 45 minute questioning
Jonathan Turley professor of law at
George Washington University did you
hear anything earth-shattering from him
no nothing earth-shattering it was all
in his opening opening testimony
I mean he did let representative Collins
get away with a lot of untruths and with
also Jeff Taylor the person who was
doing the questioning the counsel for
the Republicans they tried to bring up
again the hunter Biden Gaslight
situation so I don't think anybody on
the Democratic side would argue that it
was totally appropriate for hunter Biden
to have the job with Purisima but by the
same token that it has nothing to do
with why President President Trump was
never really interested in whether there
was actual corruption he just wanted an
investigation so it would hurt Vice
President Joe Biden in the campaign so
that sort of went on and mr. Turley
certainly could have corrected that how
but basically mr. Turley is just
repeating the same arguments which is
that there this is going on too quickly
and there's not enough evidence but
again they don't get to the point that
the Republican administration the Trump
administration has refused to cooperate
and has refused to provide the witnesses
that would indeed give and provide
additional facts and by the same token
there has been an enormous amount of
evidence that the money was withheld
from the Ukraine that the Ukraine knew
that the money was being withheld and
that President Trump was withholding the
money for the asking for the Ukraine to
say but there was an investigation into
mr. Biden and super vice and to Hunter
Biden so it's not clear what evidence
would be sufficient for mr. Turley in
fact
yeah his his whole argument is based on
the fact that the the process but the
impeachment process is flawed in his
view we've heard from these
constitutional experts three Democrats
through who were brought by the
Democrats and Jonathan Turley by the
Republicans what is this going to change
in your view Melanie if anything I don't
think it's going to change anything I
think that the they're both trying to
lay out their case the Republicans in
the House Intelligence Committee
hearings were much more fiery I think
one things we've seen that's been
interesting here is that representative
Collins who is a very fiery supporter
sometimes of president Trump's was quite
common
measured in his questioning and I think
they're trying to make the case that
there is no constitutional case for
impeachment just like the Democrats are
making out that there is a
constitutional case for impeachment and
again I think both sides are using these
law professors and the testimony they
provide to try and persuade anybody left
in the middle perhaps who already
doesn't have a view on this and yet by
the same token nearly every American
already has a view if in fact they're
watching this at all
Thank You Melanie thank you so much for
joining us Melanie stone a former
federal prosecutor commenting the
hearings today in the House Judiciary
Committee